[Music]
have you ever helped set a table and
found yourself wondering where to place
the forks or sat down to eat at a
restaurant and wondered which utensils
to use
well here are some simple traditional
etiquette tips on how to set a table
what would happen if you set a table
like this
it doesn't look good and you have to
clean up the mess before you can even
start let's try another way
to start use a placemat or tablecloth
but not both so the dishes aren't
directly on the table this is more about
looks than etiquette but it's rare to
see nothing under a plate unless you're
eating at a picnic table
set out any flowers candlesticks or
other decorations you like
candles are usually only lit at night
start with utensils for the main course
putting your dinner fork on the left and
your dinner knife on the right hand side
since these are the hands we use them
with
here's a helpful tip you always eat
outside in so to set for salad we'll put
the salad fork to the outside of the
dinner fork and the salad knife to the
outside of the dinner knife
we'll have salad first then our main
course
notice too that the knife blades are
both pointed toward the plate this is an
old tradition from a time when dinner
knives were quite sharp and it was a
sign of politeness and non-aggression to
keep them pointed away from other diners
we might have some soup and since soup
usually comes first the soup spoon goes
outside the knives since we use our
right hand to hold it
here's another tip only set the table
with what you'll need if you're not
eating soup don't set a soup spoon
now for dessert we'll have ice cream so
we'll place the dessert up top since we
don't need it for a little while
notice that the bowl of the spoon is
pointing to the left this way when it's
time to eat you just slide it down and
it's in the right spot
if you were having cake you'd set a fork
and flip it 180 degrees so it would be
right side up on the left instead
next we'll anchor our setting with the
plate you can also serve from the
kitchen then bring them to the table
the bread plate goes up into the left of
the setting and the butter knife goes on
the plate at an angle again with the
blade pointing in
there's only one spot left and that's
for the drinks
set the wine glass to the upper right
and then place the water glass to the
left of it at an angle
if you're like me and can never remember
which goes where think water wine
w-a-w-i
i they go left to right in alphabetical
order
another tip to remember left and right
with the bread and the drinks think bmw
like the car
b your bread plate is on the left m your
meal is in the middle and w your water
is on the right
lastly the napkin traditionally goes to
the left of the forks though it's okay
to put it underneath them too
for a fancier meal like this one that
takes up a lot of space we'll put it in
the middle
now we're ready to eat hopefully these
tips will be helpful the next time
you're asked to help set the table or
sit down at a fancy meal enjoy
you